Hello friends in the following recording
you'll hear a woman born in 1878 tell
you about her experiences growing up in
Los Angeles during the 1880s her name
was Bella Buford Tom Collins and there
is very little known about her except
that her father Cameron E Tom who is
pictured here was the mayor of Los
Angeles between 1882 and 1884. to give
you a little background in the 1880s the
small town of Los Angeles had a
population of 11
000 residents which was actually a
significant increase from the previous
decade a major component of all this was
the arrival of the Southern Pacific
Railroad in 1876 which connected the
town to the national rail network and by
the 1890s the discovery of oil led to
the development of the petroleum
industry in the area now Los Angeles was
not known to be a typical Wild West
Frontier Town in those days but it still
had elements of the Wild West Legacy
during the time for example vigilante
justice was sometimes employed by the
local authorities as their law
enforcement was still in development and
as one might expect there were plenty of
saloons and gambling establishments in
the area which often attracted Cowboys
Prospectors and other wild west figures
passing through the city so without
further delay let us dive into this
amazing recording of Mrs Collins now the
first woman you'll hear speaking is not
Mrs Collins but her niece Rowena who
persuaded Mr Collins to make this
remarkable recording in the first place
so we definitely have her to thank for
that the date of the audio is November
26 1964.
[Music]
sell the machine all of the kinds of
things that you can remember about your
childhood and my father's childhood from
the time that you were born here in Los
Angeles in 1878 and all the way the city
was in those days The Village was in
those days and the kinds of things that
you can recall that your father may have
told you from the time he came out here
on a horse in 1849 after having grown up
in Virginia where he was born in 1824 my
grandchildren who would never know any
of these things without you doing this
will be interested and so will all of
their children I'm sure and therefore
just tell it as it as you recall it it's
the only record at all that we have
November the 26th
1964 and I am truly grateful to my
heavenly father
for all the blessings I have received
every day of my life ever since I was
born
I've been bullied by my dear wonderful
niece Rowena to try and tell you
something about my memories as a little
child and about Los Angeles when it was
a Charming beautiful little city quiet
Green Hills beautiful Orchards of
walnuts oranges olives
not the great big sprawling dirty noisy
smelly
smoggy town that it is now
amongst my earliest memories was
going to the little stores with my
mother Main Street from Mayo Street on
to the plaza had mostly little shops on
each side of the street
on the other side of the street as about
Fourth Street there were the residences
of the people who were then the leading
people in Los Angeles and I think there
were not more than 1500 white people
here then Spanish Americans oh all sorts
and um
my mother I can remember I couldn't have
been more than five or six years old
when the loss in Main Street had a
sidewalk which was wooden it was just
wooden planks laid down and it was all
unpaved and Dusty in the summer and
frightfully muddy in the winter and the
people that came in from outside places
heaven knows where because there were no
roads came in buckboards and they tied
their horses along the hitching posts
all along the front of Main Street and I
can remember walking to the market the
the only little grocery shop in Los
Angeles with my mother and I couldn't
have been more than five years old
it was owned by a little old Dutchman
with a little side mutton chop whiskers
and his name was Henry vanderlik
I can remember as if it was yesterday on
the outside of the shop was a kind of a
thing where the brooms stood upside down
so you could select your own room if you
needed a broom which I expect we did
and inside he sold the things that we
had to buy and everything in those days
came out of barrels my mother would buy
cucumber pickles they were fished out of
a barrel with what they called a Dipper
she'd buy so much sugar and so much
flour that came out of the barrel and
was shoved in a paper bag and the cheese
he always gave me a little tiny piece of
cheese to taste everybody could taste
the cheese
and whatever he had
he had one boy in the shop to help him
came out of these barrels and things and
he was a nice old Dutchman and he built
himself up such a good business that now
the vandalik family whom I think married
was one of the oldest Castilian families
here are the
the people
so anyhow
that was that and further along there
was a little shop which was run by a man
called Mesmer that is where we bought
our shoes
I wore little shoes with what they call
Spring heels
but my Sunday shoes were soft kid
buttoned High one of each
top of each shoe was a large black silk
tassel oh I tell you I was something to
behold in those days
well the first fire station in Los
Angeles was in Main Street between first
and second Street
and it was a tremendous excitement when
there was afar there were very few of
them because there were very few houses
and very few shops to burn down
well when the far alarm sounded the
great big engine would dash out always
with magnificent white horses
and the um Hook and Ladder and all the
inhabitants would run after it to see
where the fire was they jangled bells
and whistled whistles but no Sirens
thank goodness in those days
and then the next well-known thing was
the brewery that was in Third Street
between Maine and spring and it was
owned by a man great big German called
Schwartz
and my great excitement was to walk up
Third Street with my father Mr Schwartz
with leather or I suppose rubber boots
up to his hips would be sloshing down
the suds and the water from the inside
of the place across the sidewalk and
into the gutter to go down the main
drain and he always addressed my father
as Mr Mayor good morning Mr Mayor
and once or twice I was taken into the
brewery to see how everything worked and
it was so cool and lovely and I just
loved the smell of the Hops
and we used to often walk up there
because later on when we got a little
bit older we had to walk up Third Street
to get on a cable car to take us to
school
now then
you want to know how I was dressed as a
little girl
I wore some kind of a little bodice I
can't remember what it was which had
buttons all around it and on those
buttons hung my drawers
and on top of that I wore a knitted
Petticoat hand knitted by my dear
grandmother who practically brought us
up a beautiful beautiful old lady she
was well she wasn't old for now she died
at 17 everybody thought that was
tremendous well anyhow she used to admit
these little uh petticoats for me and
they were either pink and white mostly
blue and white and those tied around my
waist on top of my drawers
then on top of that I wore a white
Petticoat which hung onto some kind of a
bodice and that always was trimmed with
white embroidery
which my grandmother sent spent hours
and years embroidering for me that was
on those then on top of that I wore some
kind of a little dress
I must have been a sight I must I must
have looked like a Christmas tree and I
think I must have been very
uncomfortable but I didn't know it that
was the way we dressed in those days
then my hair which was very long and
very thick was tied with a ribbon
on no when I went to school when I was
about six years old and went to school
that was in a nice thick plant with a
ribbon on the end but on some days that
was wild just hanging all over the place
and that was that now I can remember my
mother on one of her trips to New York
she was very delicate bringing back a
little Beaver Bonnet and a little little
coat trimmed with Beaver can you imagine
in Southern California I must have died
of heat but nobody seemed to know it
well that's that so let me think what
else well Pembroke and I went to a
kindergarten
and we were not more Pembroke was not
more than five or six and I was a year
older and we had to go on a little one
horse car
which started at the plaza and ran down
Main Street with a bell on the horse
tinkle tinkle tinkle tinkle and we knew
all the drivers until we got to our
little kindergarten which was near 7th
Street in Maine we were taught by a
little old maid who couldn't exist any
place in the world now except between
the covers of a Dickens novel
her name was Miss Mary Hoyt she dressed
in the most old-fashioned clothes even
for them dragging in the dust a little
Bonnet tied under her chin
and she carried her lunch every day in a
little Chinese basket to school well we
sat in little little benches and little
desks and things and the way we were
taught we stood up for class and on the
wall was a chart a big chart and it had
all the little three letter words that
you can think of shy and cat and dog and
oh everything we stood up
she had a long ruler and she'd call our
names now Jet Tom what's that and I'd
spell c-o-t cat and that is the way
we're taught to spell
and all of these little Sons and
Daughters of the them the well I suppose
you'd call them Los Angeles
Society leaders or whatever they were
all had their education started at this
little school
well we stayed there until Pembroke was
old enough to go to
public school I think they were one or
two well one I think here then I don't I
don't remember I was never allowed to go
to public school I was too precious to
mix with a lot of boys and things so I
was at home and going to miss Hoyts and
then on to another school later on well
that was that
so I can't think what to tell you about
the rest of the family
um my father used to come home every day
to lunch oh yes and he made had the most
beautiful garden in Los Angeles he
brought from all over the place many
beautiful semi-tropical trees which had
not been seen here then he had the first
avocado tree ever in Los Angeles or
California but in those days they called
an alligator pear tree I don't know why
but they did and he had the arakaria
bitwilly eye but the treasured tree was
an enormous rubber tree I think was
always the largest one here in Los
Angeles
and it had four massive trunks that grew
out of the original trunk and as we
children were born my mother would carve
our initials on each trunk
and so the boys were never allowed to
climb that tree because if you bruise a
rubber tree it bleeds
well my darling Pembroke loved to climb
trees
so one day he was very quick I must tell
you on the retorts that he made one day
he was at the top of this rubber tree
when he saw my father approaching rather
unexpectedly home from the office
and he tried to scramble down and as he
was scrambling down my father stopped
under the tree and he looked up and my
father always used a little a little
a stick when he walked just I don't know
how he ever got in the habit but he did
he looked up and he saw Pembroke
clamoring down the tree so he shook the
stick at him and he said Pembroke didn't
I tell you that if I ever caught you
going up that tree I'd Wallop you yes
there's my little brother he never
caught me going up the tree you caught
me coming down but of course he never
was walloped and he did all these
wonderful and sweet things he was the
most generous
loving gentle human being That Ever
Walked I think
now let me see what else can I think of
when I was little
well maybe that's enough for today maybe
we'll start again tomorrow when I can
think of a few more things except my
father's office was up for the plaza and
I expect all of you seeing the dear old
church the dear old Plaza Church
opposite
which is still standing is greater quite
a landmark here and I hope it will never
be pulled down because it's the one
thing we have really left I think they
pull down everything here that's worth
looking at
and so
I think that'll do for the day
to come around he was a Mexican that
we'd all known all our lives we were
quite little children then and he
carried on his head a small barrel and
in it wrapped up in clean white claws
were these ice cream
well they weren't cones because they
didn't have them then and we loved them
we paid five cents and we had a saucer
this stuff and of course it was only
Frozen Custard and I hate to think
nowadays where it could have been kept
in the meantime when he wasn't peddling
it that was in the summer
and in the winter he came always dressed
in white Pure White always and clean
clean as a whistle those Mexicans used
to be and when he came around in the
winter it was tamales and he pedal these
tamales and you get a real Mexican
tamale Heavens when you think for five
cents and we just were crazy for them
and for him and he was here for many
many many many years
and um
Gardens and on the south side then there
weren't more I would say than 12 houses
and the beach was just one wide
beautiful white sand beach not a house
not a tent nothing was allowed to be
built on the sand in those days and we
used to go down there as soon as school
was out the Exodus was marvelous a great
big wagon would come in from the ranch
with the horses and bedding and know
everything you can think of was piled in
there and the Chinese cook went down and
we went down in the in the carriage with
the horses and we'd get down there and
then everybody the the boys would go
wild from then on they never had shoes
or stockings on they were in their
bathing suits they were good swimmers
and they were quite little we went I
went down there when I was eight weeks
old so of course I wasn't in swimming I
hope I don't like it now even so anyhow
the bar the everyday uh the scene would
go out two boats would go with what you
call the net but we called it the sane
in between and they'd drag this thing in
and then the Chinese cook and my father
where was would go down on the beach and
they caught hundreds of fish the salt
that you've never seen on the market and
they'd stand there and they'd they'd say
well they'd have that one they'd have a
red yellow tail they'd have a croaker
they'd oh I can't tell you what they'd
have and they'd pay practically nothing
for them five cents were a big fish and
the fish were all flapping and fresh and
occasionally there was a lobster not too
often and then we had a dog and the
dog's name was Jack he was black he was
a mongrel but he was loving he was
pembroke's dog and he never left
Pembroke but Pembroke was quite a little
boy when we first started going down
there and he liked paddling in the ocean
and going and swimming and every time
he'd go down to the beach with the dog
following and start going in this dog
would bark and rush in and grab him by
the seat of his pants and pull him out
well that didn't please him very much
but he had to put up with it and we
every year from the time I was born the
first summer I was born and I was born
on the 3rd of July
until I went away East was I there for
three months and we had the best times I
think of our entire lives in that place
at Santa Monica
now the oh I forgot to tell you that in
the old house in Los Angeles well it
wasn't old then we had four parrots
and they were loose in the trees my
mother cut their wings one of their
wings to keep them from flying away and
they'd come down when they wanted their
meals but they all talked and chattered
but one of them could imitate my
mother's voice and as a little little
well Pembroke was not more than six or
seven then he'd be playing down by the
Sankey
and my mother would go to a back window
upstairs and called Pembroke and he'd
say yes ma'am I must tell you that on
those days we said yes ma'am and no sir
yes ma'am and he'd come running up my
mother would tell him what she wanted
him to do but the parrot learned to call
him and this parrot black he would sit
in the top of the tree out there and
call Pam broke and he'd come running up
the hill yes ma'am until they found out
it was the parrot and he was madder than
a Hatter no oh I always had a kind of a
I guess motherly feeling towards him and
when we went to miss hard School
at the ages of oh I guess five and six
maybe less I always felt I had to look
after him I was responsible and believe
it or not I was a very shy child I was
frightened of everything well
this one day at school Miss Hoyt
promptly said she'd want to know if any
of the children could recite little
poems and of course Mr show off was the
first one oh he knew a poem I must tell
you he listed very much in those days
because he'd have several falls
downstairs and things and his front
teeth had been knocked out oh he knew
nice little poem a nice little poem so
Miss Howard said what he recited and he
stood up
and I must tell you all of these people
with that Kindergarten now many of them
are still alive although we're all
pretty old and decrepit but we're still
alive
and we've always been friends all these
all these many years but he stood up and
this is the poem as I was going to the
lake I made a little rattlesnake he ate
so much jelly cake it made his little
belly ache now that was too much for me
I burst into tears and I was told to go
home so I took him home
and formed my mother I would never go
back to that school again I was
disgraced he said Billy in front of
everybody barely fancy saying that
well I guess we were different in those
days I don't know I expect we were
nowadays Not only would you say it but
you'd show it if you wanted to
and um well I can't think of the little
things that happened so many little
funny things used to happen to us when
we were children oh now one of my very
earliest Recollections I couldn't have
been more than four or five years old
and it was on the 4th of July
and there's there was a procession
Always A procession always and it always
came down Main Street
naturally that was the street and my
father
was riding in it on a horse
and they were going to stop just in
front of our big Gates just there
because we of course we had the Mansion
you know
and somebody was going to make a speech
and at the right moment I was going to
be pushed out to the hand a beautiful
great big bouquet
well the bouquet was all got ready and I
was dressed up in numerous petticoats
and whatnotes and things and
somebody was in the middle of making a
speech and I disappeared and nobody
could find me know me no bouquet no
curtsies no anything so the parade went
on
everybody looked for me and I was
offered I was found hiding under the
Hedge with a very wielded little bouquet
in my hot hands
well what else can I tell you I don't
know
I think I was a funny little girl I know
I was very chic and dressy I think more
so than most of my little friends I
think that my grandmother who
practically brought us up because my
mother was so delicate as I said before
I think she kind of thought of me as a
funny little doll
well perhaps
so now I will close until I can think of
something else
when my father first came to Los Angeles
after a very exciting and eventful life
he bought a large portion of land which
ran from Third Street it was a half a
block between Third Street and 4th
Street fronting on Main Street and
extending to Los Angeles Street at the
back
Third Street was only a little unpaved
alley but my father named it Mayo Street
after his mother Abigail
mail Tom
and in that land was an old adobe house
which was at least the walls or at least
three feet thick and my mother used that
always as a sort of a storage room
my father then built this beautiful old
house which even nowadays would have
been a lovely home it was called the Tom
Mansion no less
it had large beautiful rooms well
proportioned the the library was paneled
so was the dining room it had seven
bedrooms
and my mother had her own Suite with her
sitting room upstairs her little
dressing room and her bedroom and in
that bedroom we were all born
there were four of us
my two eldest Brothers Cameron and Kate
SP who were born within a very short
time of each other then there was quite
a little break and then I was born the
first girl in the Tom family for a
generation and my darling darling
brother Pembroke was born I think 15
months after I was
we were like twins all of our Lives I
never loved anybody as much or more
my two Elder Brothers hung together I
don't think they thought much of the two
younger ones
now in this large place
there was an old wooden Flume which ran
through half of it
it was called by the Mexicans the zanka
we kids called it the Sankey
and that was only used for irrigation
purposes never for the house or anything
like that I was never allowed to go near
it I was too precious I might have got
my feet wet but the boys went and they
picked up all sorts of little frogs and
all sorts of little fish and whatnots
and we were looked after but from the
time we were born
with by three Mexican girls
and afterwards when they left and the
Chinese started filtering in my mother
always had Chinese we had for years a
Chinese Gardener chikai who had been a
doctor in China and it was always doing
things with people particularly Pembroke
who was always getting hurt
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign